What you just saw, was almost a recreation of the Solomon Asch study, a really
famous social psychology study on conformity. What they did was they showed
their participants a standard line, and then had them compare it to three other
lines, kind of like the one I showed you. They had them do this about 18 times.
Now, this was a relatively easy task, when the independent variable wasn't
manipulated. People messed up less than 1% of the time. However, when the
independent variable was manipulated, people messed up about 37% of the time.
So, what was the independent variable. Well, it was the people that were in the
room saying the response is allowed. Out of all of the people in the room there
was only one real participant. The rest of the people were confederates.
Meaning they worked for the research team, but they appeared to be real
participants. After a while of answering these questions, the researchers had
the confederates, incorrectly answer the question, on purpose. Because they
wanted to see if hearing these five or six people answer the question
incorrectly, would actually sway the participants' response. And well, as it
turns out, it did. Let's go to Susan for some more details.